they're one of the most destructive
natural phenomena on Earth
vast rotating thunderstorms are
self-sustaining heat engines
the winds can reach speeds of over 200
miles per hour
and when they make land the consequences
can be devastating
from extreme rainfall
Storm surges it's amazingly powerful way
of focusing the sun's energy into one
little destructive package but what
turns a peaceful patch of ocean into
Nature's Most Powerful storm
[Music]
tropical Cyclones have different names
depending on where they originate
typhoons in the Northwest Pacific
Cyclones in the Indian Ocean and South
Pacific
and hurricanes in the North Atlantic and
Northeast Pacific
what hurricane
um comes from the language of the Taino
who were a Caribbean indigenous people
moved into the Spanish language and then
into the English language from there
a 17th century colonist recalled that
the terror of the storm was such that I
thought the emblem of hell and the last
dissolution of all things
Alexander Hamilton who grew up in the
Caribbean wrote that the noise
accompanying a hurricane would strike
astonishment into angels
the hurricane has already whipped across
the Bahamas throughout history
hurricanes have been wreaking havoc on
the coastal communities in their path
storm warnings along the Florida coast
and remembering the disasters of other
years there is haste among the residents
to prepare for the word
today scientists Define a hurricane as a
rapidly rotating storm system that
originates over tropical waters and has
closed low-level circulation
so how do they form
hurricanes often begin life as a
tropical wave that's a low pressure area
that moves across the Atlantic from
Africa
a number of conditions need to align to
turn the wave into a hurricane
sea surface temperatures of at least
26.5 degrees Celsius down to a depth of
50 meters
near the ocean's surface there need to
be converging winds forcing air to rise
and form storm clouds
up in the atmosphere too much wind in
the wrong direction can tear apart a
hurricane so you need low wind shear
that's the change in direction and speed
of winds at increasing Heights there
needs to be high relative humidity from
the surface to the mid levels of the
atmosphere
the storm has to be more than five
degrees of latitude from the equator
that's about 200 miles
Americans are sort of like parasitic
feedback loop by taking heat out of the
ocean and turning it into water droplets
it creates the wind that takes more heat
out of the ocean it's basically living
off the ocean's heat and doing its own
thing with it
[Music]
a hurricane Spin comes from something
called the Coriolis effect
to understand this think of a spinning
playground roundabout
imagine a ball thrown from The Middle
even if the ball is thrown forward it
will curve to the right on Earth this
happens on a huge scale
this is crucial to the way hurricanes
form because the faster air moves the
stronger the Coriolis effect that's how
you get that typical Twisted form that's
diagnostic of a hurricane when you see
it from space
and once the wind speed reaches 74 miles
per hour the tropical storm is
officially classified as a hurricane
it's amazingly powerful way of focusing
the sun's energy into one little
destructive package
hi I'm Katie and I'd
want to read more of our coverage of
extreme weather why not
description to The Economist you'll get
daily and weekly analysis of global
Affairs you can meet us online and in
the app and listen to our audio Edition
for the best offer click the link and
now back to the film
already historic and strength hurricane
Patricia on a collision course with
Mexico its winds right now far more
powerful in 2015 Hurricane Patricia
broke records with wind speeds of 215
miles per hour
even for a typical hurricane the heat
energy pumped into the storm is equal to
the average rate at which the United
States uses electrical power
that's the whole generating capacity of
the country powering just one storm
and wind speed isn't the only weapon in
A hurricane's Arsenal
the thing that powers a hurricane is
warm air moist air giving up its
moisture to form droplets in these huge
clouds well those droplets are water and
they are going to fall
and it's a lot of precipitation
hurricanes can release up to 2 billion
tons of rainfall every day
water causes 90 percent of deaths from
hurricanes and almost half of those come
from Storm surges
people are dying they don't have homes
the City of New Orleans will never be
the same
when a hurricane makes landfall the
power of its winds pushes the ocean
forward
this wall of water approaching the shore
is called a storm surge
with Hurricane Katrina the storm surge
did a huge amount of the damage
it was fairly monstrous it was about
eight meters tall
it broke New Orleans water defenses the
levees and the dikes that wall of water
being pushed in was a key part of why
that particular hurricane turned into
such a terrible disaster
the sheer force of the wind of course
causes a lot of damage when you're hit
by a hurricane also that wind can be so
like localized into tornadoes because
the wind at the surface can't move as
fast as the wind is moving above and you
get this extra twisty thing
once the hurricane starts to move across
land it's no longer able to draw energy
from the ocean
forcing the storm to eventually
dissipate
but the devastation Left Behind can take
years to rebuild
in the United States tropical Cyclones
cost on average 22.4 billion dollars per
storm
this is far more than other extreme
weather events droughts cost an average
of 11.1 billion dollars per season
currently there's no scientific
consensus on whether climate change
affects Hurricane's Behavior
but it is clearly influencing the
systems that feed the storms
the question of what climate change is
doing in to the power of hurricanes is
pretty vexed
models suggest that over the course of
this Century as the Earth warms up
hurricanes are unlikely to become more
common in fact their frequency might
decrease slightly
but the storms that do make land are
becoming even more destructive
if you have more warm sea water then the
hurricanes have more room to grow and to
power themselves up
more than 90 percent of the extra heat
produced by global warming is absorbed
by the oceans
warmer oceans mean more destructive
power for hurricanes
there's a general principle that the
warmer the air the more moisture it
holds extreme rainstorm events are going
to become yet more extreme in a warmer
world
the classic example of this is Hurricane
Harvey which hit Texas in 2017.
Hurricane Harvey and its torturously
slow March along the Gulf Coast of Texas
Harvey was widely reckoned to be roughly
the worst rainstorm event that's ever
been in the United States since records
began
there's been analysis suggesting that a
hurricane that's as wet as Harvey is
about three times more likely given
global warming
the Damage Done by a storm surge depends
on where sea level is when the surge
starts and so at a high tide a storm
surge is worse than at a low tide but
there's also this long-term secular
change in sea level that is driven by
climate change and that drives sea level
up the higher sea level starts the worse
the storm surge will be
hurricane Ian which hit the coast of
Florida in 2022 was working with a sea
level that's about 30 centimeters higher
than it was a century ago and so you
know that's higher water that you can
push further inland
and while scientists are yet to prove
there is a link to climate change
hurricanes also appear to be traveling
slower
one study found the average forward
moving speed of North Atlantic
hurricanes decreased by 17 percent
between 1944 and 2017.
a hurricane that moves slowly bashes the
coast with winds just as strong as it
would if it's moving fast so slower
moving hurricanes are not fun they sound
like they're a bit better but they are
actually worse in terms of the damage to
human life
as these heat engines intensify their
destruction
understanding how they're affected by
climate change and preparing for their
landfall are essential parts of
Mankind's battle to adapt to a warming
world
no amount of checking
um global warming is going to actively
reduce the intensity of hurricanes over
anything like a human life life lifespan
the hurricanes are here they're part of
the system and so people have to get
used to ways of protecting themselves
against the hurricanes
I'm Oliver Morton I'm a senior editor at
The Economist for more of our coverage
of extreme weather and climate change
please click on the link below thanks
for watching and if you don't please
subscribe
[Music]